Our mission is to make the world more open and connected...
...and the people who work at Facebook really believe that.
I'm really proud for Facebook to be number one...
...on the list of great places to work on Glassdoor.
I am constantly inspired by the people I work with every day...
...and the caliber of talent all concentrated in one place brings on this infectious energy.
I see people that are focused on a goal, are committed and will not stop for anything.
The passion that they bring to the company and the energy,...
...it's one of the things I love the most about working here.
The common theme that I've always seen through the whole time is just...
...us being really focused on our mission to make the world more open and connected...
...and to really make an impact with our product.
And that's something that you know will always be a...
...like a core part of our culture and just our thumbprint as a company.
Knowing that you can put out a feature today...
...and that it will be in front of a billion people next week...
...is just something that is really hard to find in the industry...
...and something that I'm happy to take advantage of every day I come to work.